grading frustrations among ccsd families
during the covid pandemic do continue
christian that's right well data shows
more children
failed the fall semester than in
previous school years after
transitioning to distance education
kristen drummond shows us how the
district is considering adjustments to
the grading process
the district wants to upgrade the
grading process and needs parent
feedback
now this has been in the works for a
while but the pandemic added
urgency as more students fail classes
it's very very frustrating jamie johnson
watches her sophomore son
struggle with school during the pandemic
all of his grades right now are failing
in all of his classes
what kind of student was he like before
covet i mean he was your average b
c student a in his like electives she
and other parents questioned the current
grading policy
after statistics show an increase of f
and d's
issue during the fall semester as we
start the fourth quarter
are we looking at damage control a
concern raised during the virtual ccsd
grading reform family feedback
session a meeting that focuses on more
than just grades
received by students during the pandemic
what we realize is that we are in need
of a systematic change throughout
clark county school district ccsd staff
say there's inconsistency
not only among schools but in
departments our students need
equitable grading policies to provide an
accurate reflection of their learning
that means possibly changing the grading
scale that's going to be the first step
to get a level playing field the
district encourages families to fill out
a survey and offer their suggestions
but johnson and others want a solution
now to the current problem
this long into the year it's like how do
you even come back from it
a link to the parent survey is on our
website 8newsnow.com
along with dates and times for other
sessions in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now
a high school principal revealed ccsd
expects a drop in the graduation rates
this year
summer school is already being discussed
as well as graduation ceremonies
schools may schedule not only a spring
commencement but summer and fall too so
students have an opportunity to
celebrate with their classmates brian